hey you guys
time for another movie retrospective
doing some vincent price action yeah
this is a good one i like this one yeah
i thought you might yeah it's good it's
kind of like minimalistic and bleak kind
of
kind of sadistic
you know it's almost like a story
marquita side would tell but it has some
action in it too it's pretty it's good
it's good good moves yeah this one yeah
this is the 1968 film witch finder
general
which
okay so in the u.s this was actually
released by american international
pictures
uh they distributed it and they changed
the title to the conqueror worm
because
you know aip had a lot of success with
vincent price's uh you know edgar allan
poe adaptations uh you know that had uh
roger gorman directed and um and that
had vincent price in them so it's kind
of like so they're like well we want
this to look like it's the same series
even though it's not and even though
this is totally not based on an edgar
allen poe story yeah so like yeah so
like the american one they just had
vincent price like read part of edgar
allan poe's poem to conquer a worm and
they put it like at the front in the
back and then they're just like and then
this is a po picture it's it's really
not this is a historical well
it's not
super historically accurate but it's
kind of like based on some real [ __ ]
that happened
yeah what's funny is that uh
usually when you say vincent price i
kind of associate it with with the pose
stuff yeah and the post i was kind of
tongue-in-cheek and [ __ ] you know
he's chewing up the scenery and [ __ ]
acting you know over the top i wouldn't
say over the top it's just the tone
is usually him hamming it up you know
but not this one
this one yeah and this one this one is
sucking hardcore all right he plays a
bad guy and he's like he's
he's real sadistic you know he's like
something out of a damn decide story you
know taking advantage of his power
you know abusing young women and [ __ ]
you know he's got making them have sex
with him with the promises of like
letting family members go out of the
witch trial and then he betrays him and
looking it's bad then he loans them out
to his friends and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
then a bunch of torture happens witch
type torture they're beating on women
and
the guys are kind of getting off on it
being cruel to [ __ ] women and [ __ ]
it's it's
it's bizarre it's good i mean for 1968
this is uh pretty hardcore it's not like
i mean it's very very tame by standard
it's not gory or anything it's just a
subject matter and it's violent i mean
it is violent because violent and gory
aren't the same thing no it's violent
but it's not very gory but it's like the
subject matter and it's kind of
psychological
yeah
because they're they're abusing their
power over people and it's kind of
accurate
you know yeah how they were they knew
what they were doing was a scam
you know they're [ __ ] criminals you
know these witch finders pretty much i
mean okay so what this is basically
about now it's interesting that you said
that you associated vincent price with
kind of more over-the-top or like hammy
so you know what i mean which and that's
not i don't mean that because man i
[ __ ] love vincent price he's like one
of my favorites it's good interestingly
the guy that directed this and we'll get
into this in a little bit too because
it's kind of like a tragic story
uh it was named michael reeves and um
this was the third movie that he'd made
and actually when he first
was talking about like directing this
movie and like the producers of this
movie and everything like that this is
actually based on a novel which had come
out a couple of years prior which was
you know a historical fiction type thing
about matthew hopkins who like i said
was a real guy
so um the script was originally written
for
donald pleasance they wanted donald
pleasance to play matthew hopkins the
witchfinder general
because they wanted the tone of the
movie
they wanted it to be more like uh they
wanted to portray matthew hopkins as
almost kind of like not bumbling
necessarily but they want him to be like
some kind of like authority figure but
who was also kind of like uh laughable
you know what i'm saying and they
thought that donald pleasance would play
that better but the thing about it was
that the british studio tigon so this
isn't a hammer and it isn't amicus this
is a tiger on a much smaller one i think
this cost less than a hundred thousand
pounds to make actually that's a good
flick though it is yeah um so but
american international pictures fronted
some of the money and they were like no
we want vincent price because he was
like under contract with them
and very famously at least in horror
circles in british horror circles uh
michael reeves the director and vincent
price did not get along because michael
reeves basically as soon as vincent
price arrived in the uk to work on this
michael reeves made one he didn't meet
him at the airport which was kind of
like snotty and also he was basically
said um i didn't want you but i'm stuck
with you all right so they didn't really
get along yeah and it's it's funny
because so they so they were like have
they were like at each other's throats
pretty much the whole time uh vincent
price said you know i didn't really uh
he said he wasn't michael reeves wasn't
very good at communicating with actors i
didn't really know what he wanted from
me
and you know it's like he
at one point i think the there's a very
famous story that vincent price got
really pissed off at him like when they
were shooting a scene or whatever and he
said i've made 87 films like what have
you done right and then michael reeve
said i've made three good ones
which i was like ooh shade but vincent
price did think that was funny now the
thing about it though is that
so vincent price actually ended up
playing this because he didn't really
know what michael reeves wanted from him
so he ended up playing it like kind of
like restrained and like kind of
sinister he got it right yeah and then
later on uh vincent price like after he
saw the movie he was like oh i see what
he was going for now and he actually did
write like a very long letter to michael
reeves like saying i see what you were
going for now and he actually later
vincent price considered this like one
of his best uh performances although at
the time he said it was like very
stressful at the time because they
weren't getting along and he wasn't
entirely sure how he was supposed to
play it but it worked out pretty good
this is i i think it's the best
uh film that i've seen from from price i
liked it
yeah he's got a lot of cool films you
know what i mean he does so many oh you
know some of this
they're they're each one a lot of it's
kind of heavy yeah but it's still cool i
like it there's a lot of spa like dr
phebes and all that kind of [ __ ]
but this one's got a grit to it it's
okay when it starts it's got these
spooky ass [ __ ] black and white
photographs of [ __ ] faces and [ __ ] up
close
it kind of reminded me of the spooky
intro and outro of like the night
gallery remember the night gallery oh
yeah i love that show and i was going
this might be something here you know
and then as it went along it kind of had
the tone of a good night gallery
episode
but in the scope of a movie yeah you
notice that yeah it is kind of and
another thing similar because because
you know how night gallery had that
darkness to it yeah it was it was it was
like that and i i was expecting
i didn't really know what to expect but
you know when vincent price shows up in
there i was kind of expecting well he's
going to get kind of goofy like in dr
phebes or something
no no he he did that [ __ ] [ __ ] spooky
straight through the whole thing he was
very sinister
and he real good and he looked great his
face yeah i loved his hair and
everything the outfit that would make a
great halloween costume yeah and then
all the supporting actors and then the
hero of the story i liked it
uh
there's a lot of themes happening in
this movie
um it's about duty and rules and and
honor and laws
you know this soldier
has to avenge what what went down with
his in-laws and his wife
because this witch fighter raped his
[ __ ] girlfriend his fiancee it killed
his father-in-law to be you know
so he's got to get revenge he can't use
the system because the system's not
going to doesn't have his back you know
this witch finder really has the
authority
and it's and it's not his authority as a
soldier they get there's a civil war
going on between his factions the round
heads and they're fighting cromwell
yeah no cromwell
and then
the royalists yeah royals and um
so he's got a war to wage on one hand
but he has to figure out how the hell
he's gonna [ __ ]
get revenge on this dude and um
is it vengeance or is it justice if he
asked me it was justice because the
system wasn't going to
bring justice to this dude he was a
menace to humanity at large
oh he definitely was he just made a list
and the real guy was even worse yeah i
mean this dude's running around
in in england just
killing [ __ ] at will and making money
making money off of it just by accusing
people of being witches and then proving
them as a witch
and
he knew it was fake
you know and this soldier knew it was
fake it was really
the moral of the story is that
there are certain circumstances where a
man should [ __ ] do what he has to do
for the benefit of mankind
yeah that's the moral of this story and
like i said and a lot of people have
pointed this out this movie is almost
kind of like structured like a western
yeah it is and there's even kind of some
stuff there's like kind of gunfights
there's like a horse chase like you know
it's chase on
you know horseback 1500's
mean yeah it's uh yeah i just let the
audience know that we're not talking
about eighteen hundreds or you know it's
sixteen hundreds actually sixteen
hundreds okay flintlocks are a lot of
stuff that they were wearing the helmets
i kind of associated with like late
1500s like that but that's sick early
1600s yeah
maybe you know they were wearing helmets
they're very similar to the conquistador
uh you know 1500's that would have been
used in batch locks so yeah you're right
been about 1600s yeah i think this was
about mid-1600s like 1650 something
something like that like i said during
one of the english civil wars so
basically like what the context is and i
kind of want to get a little bit into
because i don't know like a huge amount
about this time period but i did kind of
like want to know how accurate this was
to the actual guy like actual matthew
hopkins um who
uh vincent price is playing in this
movie so basically what the what the
story of the movie is set during the
english civil war like you said um
cromwell's roundheads versus the
royalists and honestly it's just it's
kind of got to a point where uh law and
order is kind of broken down to a large
degree yeah so into this and the intro
sets that up yeah so they kind of the
law order's broken down between these
two warren factions and this witch
fighter [ __ ] is using it as an
opportunity to [ __ ] take advantage
yeah he wasn't the only one
doing this kind of uh you know pulling
this kind of crap but he's the most
famous because he was the one that was
responsible for the most deaths um you
know what i mean so he's basically he
took it upon himself they don't actually
know too much about his like younger
life although he was actually raised by
puritans um and he was really into like
so i don't know if he actually like
believed in witches or if he just got
off on torturing people and getting paid
for it maybe it was a combination of
both things but he essentially
um his dad like i said was a some kind
of like um fun like uh what do you call
it like a puritan
minister or whatever and when james the
first had come in because prior to like
james the first coming in and please
correct me if i'm wrong people that know
more about english history i feel like
witchcraft was kind of a crime but not
really like they weren't really killing
people for it but once james the first
came in he had some kind of like hard-on
for like oh there's witches everywhere
and we need to like eradicate them and
so he passed all these laws
that um you know that now
because before it's like witchcraft was
technically only illegal like if you
used it to kill somebody or hurt
somebody to commit a crime to commit a
crime whereas after james the first it
was kind of like okay well now
witchcraft is just illegal across the
board and you know they brought in like
executions for it and [ __ ] like that and
so i feel like into this
context this kind of like historical
context you had people like matthew
hopkins who he had no authority he
wasn't anything it's like he had owned a
pub at some point they think they think
he might have been a lawyer but he just
got it into his head that hey
there's no real authority so i can just
go around from town to town
and
extract confessions from people
and then hand them over and then get
like paid and the reason that they
could extract confessions is because
they started torturing people which
prior to
this time period was not really legal
yeah um well all that stuff you know
and other things that i've read about
this whole period the way which finders
worked
i was always always under the impression
that they knew it was a grift
they i mean they had yeah because they
only applied it when they could yeah
yeah i mean
they did it on the week and then in
times of of basically moral panics so
they were opportunists
did they believe witches existed
probably probably i think most people
did they realized today a lot of times
probably no they were accusing innocent
people yeah
when they couldn't find witches they
invented witches
because they were getting paid and like
i said you know obviously the more you
like torture people they're gonna be
like fine yes i'm a [ __ ] witch just
please stop doing that i mean obviously
well they just let's get this out with
because they're going to kill you anyway
well yeah i mean honestly once you get
accused
you're pretty much [ __ ] yeah and um so
so to that extent like the stuff that
they show in this movie
in the sense that he was going they did
kind of actually film this right around
the area where he lived like in east
anglia and stuff like that and all these
towns that he went to and the thing the
um the guy that he's like a priest he
was a catholic priest wasn't he like the
uncle of the guys yeah
well that was a real guy too they did
kill that guy well yeah and they said he
was an idolater yeah and you you could
probably you know catholicism you could
make that accusation they had all these
statues and [ __ ] yeah so you say yeah
you're an idolater so therefore you're a
witch yeah because you're a catholic
yeah which that's the crazy [ __ ] but
that was that was that's the kind of
leaps of logic that which finders did
and there was no way out
if you can just make up arbitrary rules
there's never any way out and this [ __ ]
like it's like anything else it's moral
panics and virtue signaling and it's
just it happens in mankind over and over
again it's something that [ __ ]
[ __ ] do when they can get away with
it well and it's it's just it wasn't
even the thing of you know there'd been
law and order breaking down because
there was like you know civil war was
going on but as usually happens in in
times like this there was also a lot of
poverty a lot of starvation a lot of
disease so people were you know weakened
they were looking for some kind of
solution so the thing about it is that
matthew hopkins comes in as they show in
this movie and he basically goes from
town to town and like some of the towns
people were like asking him to come
there yeah come ruin our witches out
because
the witches are causing like all of
these problems like my livestock are
dying like my family died of disease
blah blah blah i'm getting poorer so
witches must be so witches right i just
did it um so so basically you know
people like matthew hopkins because like
i said he wasn't the only one
but he's just the most famous because i
believe he was directly responsible for
at least for killing at least 200 women
at least uh that you know that they know
of like i said he was he was the worst
one another thing's a dead giveaway is
that they always kind of they had it not
always but they had a tendency to go
after the weakest women in that society
yeah it was usually like older women or
women that were like unpopular or had
you know that they didn't have really a
means of support or defense they weren't
of high status
they tended not to to do that so
they know that this shit's fake they
know they had to have known because they
wouldn't they were they were accusing
the people of witchcraft they were
accusing the people they wanted to get
rid of as witchcraft yeah so you know
they already wanted to get rid of them
so that must be a witch
yeah like they're not like
claiming that the queen of england is a
witch that gets you shot well yeah
because she just turned around and
crushed that kill him yeah
that's what would happen it's always
somebody who's defenseless well yeah
they're always going after them
punching down you know
um you know that's what you do so so
like i said this is in a sense
historically accurate in the sense that
yes there was a matthew hopkins yes he
did go from town to town you know
village to village uh killing people the
scene they show of him uh you know
torturing and killing that priest uh
that's pretty historically accurate um
the stuff about him having the uh the
right-hand man john stern uh that was a
real guy although interestingly in real
life as far as they know john stern was
actually started out as a witch finder
and matthew hopkins was like his protege
um but then later like as it went on
like it kind of you know the
relationship switched also in real life
matthew hopkins was only in his 20s when
he was doing this [ __ ] he died young uh
he didn't get murdered sadly um and his
reign of terror kind of only lasted for
about a year and a half
and um
even like even back then during this
like time period
he was doing this [ __ ] he was going
around villages saying that parliament
had given him the power and he gave
himself the title which finder general
like the people didn't do that he called
himself that he's like yeah parliament
totally told me that and that was total
[ __ ] nobody told he just went and
like made it up and uh and that's what
he did so they kind of evidence that he
was grifted yeah so they kind of go into
that a little bit in this movie um i
think i think vincent price at one point
says you know oh they're calling me
witchfinder general that's [ __ ] he
actually gave himself that title yeah
but he didn't have any right to it he
didn't have like i said he had no
authority of any
kind you know what i mean he just
decided took it upon himself that he was
gonna go root out witches and go around
torturing people and mostly hanged them
uh there is one scene in this one which
is actually pretty horrific yeah where
he goes to i think it's i think it's
lavanam yeah and uh they which was
actually shot in the real lavender
market square i think um except they you
know covered it with dung and straw and
whatnot but um yeah were they where they
set up this it looks like a gallowsy
crucifixy thing but then they they tie
this woman
to a ladder and then like put her up
there and then they have a fire there
and they'll like lower her into it like
face first into the fire i don't know
how accurate that is but i was like
that's pretty that's some pretty [ __ ]
another one that was a trip is they had
this old woman
they had her all tied up with three
other people and they were gonna
throw them in the water to see you know
who would float if they floated they
were a witch if they [ __ ] sank they
were if they sank and drowned they're
like oh well they were innocent but
they're dead now anyway because they
yeah and she's this old toothless hag in
her 70s [ __ ] begging for her life no
you can't kill me i'm with child
and they all start laughing yeah okay
she went out they threw her ass over the
[ __ ]
over the bridge and they had her on a
line
and she died and he goes oh she was
innocent yeah yeah oh well oh well she
went to god now it's fine this is like
yeah this is like super [ __ ] up you
can't kill me i'm i'm with child
yeah we kind of laughed too because it
was like a toothless old time yeah yeah
i was like well nice try at least she is
like she just tried poor poor thing but
yeah so
uh so yeah so
even though so like i said even though
this does have like some historically
accurate [ __ ] in it um
i was gonna say that you know the real
matthew hopkins like i said was actually
much much younger he was only in his 20s
uh which considerably younger than
vincent price was in this movie and he
actually died really young matthew the
real matthew hopkins i think he was only
26 or 27. uh unfortunately no one hacked
and hacked him to death with an axe like
you see in here because that was pretty
awesome they gave him a better ending in
this movie uh yeah i think he just died
of tuberculosis although um like i said
his reign of terror only lasts about a
year and a half at which point uh the
law intervene is like dude what the [ __ ]
are you even doing and the tide public
titan started to turn against him
because he was like being excessive and
they're just like bro you need to like
knock that [ __ ] off and so it was almost
kind of like a really quick like which
panic where everybody kind of freaked
out about it and then everyone kind of
like came to their senses and so he had
pretty much been
um
you know he he had gotten to a point
very quickly where people were just kind
of like yeah we're not doing that
anymore and then he just died they think
it was of tb they're not actually i
actually like the hero in this movie
he's kind of he's this british soldier
he's kind of like the british version of
luke skywalker and yeah he's a round
head so soldier yeah
kind of in the in the rebellion i guess
i guess you could say
and um
but uh no he
he goes after darth vader
he gets his yeah he's kind of just a
young heroic guy trying to avenge his
fiancee's honor yeah because i mean the
story of the people from this [ __ ]
monster yeah the story behind this i
mean it's pretty much a straight ahead
like revenge tale yeah it's very direct
yeah there's not a lot of extraneous
stuff it's pretty short it's only about
84 minutes just just right length but
yeah i think that actor's name is ian
ogilvy that played him um and he's uh he
yeah he's one in the roundhead uh army
his name is richard marshall his
character name and he has um i can't
remember the name of the village like
where his girlfriend lives but that's
his fiancee
uh and her name is sarah
and she lives with her uncle who is a
catholic priest
so what ends up happening is that
uh witchfinder
you know vincent price and his sidekick
who is like his muscle sort of uh you
know he's the one that tortures and gets
the confessions out of people so they
turn up in this village and start
[ __ ] with uh sarah's uncle because
he's an idolater and she basically to
try to save her uncle's life because she
knows how this [ __ ] is gonna go she
basically offers herself sexually to
like vincent price would be like hey
please like don't kill him he kind of
let her know that there was that that he
might be interested in that that he
could yeah she accepted she didn't just
allow for herself she she was presented
that as an option
and she was like okay well and she said
later she's like i didn't want to do it
obviously she just didn't want her uncle
to get killed yeah um so she ends up
doing that and vincent price is like
okay yes please and just gets in with
that and then meanwhile his um you know
his sidekick john stern is out like you
know winching at the pubs and whatnot oh
fun fact because you were talking about
how you know how in hammer movies that
everything would be just like
boobalicious and everything
and you said there's not really a lot of
boobs and i mean sarah is really the
only female character and she you know
she wears like dresses from that time
but it's not like overly boobalicious
but
straight up they're honest about what it
is they're doing go ahead go ahead but i
was gonna say that uh unbeknownst to the
director i guess one of the producers
said we need to film like a bunch of
extra nudity for the german version
right you know what i mean so when they
released it in germany it apparently had
a whole bunch of extra scenes of like
boobage in there yeah uh so they did
yeah i was just i just remembered that
because it was like a hammer in the
[ __ ] in the right german but honestly
there's really not there's one sex scene
but that's pretty much it and it's like
so it's kind of like so vincent price
starts taking advantage and he and he
actually does he's like oh okay well
i'll just keep your uncle like in prison
instead of like torturing him and
killing him like i was gonna do uh as
long as uh you're letting me tap that
but then um he has to go out of town
right uh for like for something like
somebody calls him over to the next
village and while he's gone his sidekick
actually rapes her yeah after which
vincent price is like oh now she's
sloppy seconds it's like so he doesn't
want to do it anymore yeah so he doesn't
want her anymore um so i'm like that's
nice and they go ahead and execute and
so then they just go ahead and execute
her uncle anyway yeah and then like
leave her alone and at which point like
the boyfriend richard marshall like
their you know fiance he finds out about
like all the [ __ ] that's going on and
finds out that these two [ __ ]
are like in the town where his
girlfriend lives there's no rape scene
in it not really it's just it's it's
implied i mean it's
you see him like laying on her like
grunting and stuff and her screaming
yeah it's like then they kind of angles
are in a certain way and it's just yeah
just to let you know that this [ __ ]
happened yeah and i mean honestly like
the suggestion of it and it's not just
like rape and stuff but it's just
remember that one scene where it's like
there's this other woman like who they
don't name but she's like in the dungeon
yeah and they're beating up and then
he's like john stern's just like beating
the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of her and stuff
like that so this is like i said it's a
violent thing is that that woman
remember she got her eye poked out
eventually i think it was that same
woman when it was yeah i think it was
yeah and that was the one that they
burned on the damn ladder
later on as a surprise
her [ __ ] her boyfriend or her husband
when it was on a quest for revenge
against the [ __ ] witch fight he
tracks witch fighter down too
yeah and tries to like yeah try to kill
him so you know the soldier guy he isn't
the only dude that's sucking trying to
get revenge on this dude
well yeah you go around killing innocent
women that's gonna happen and then the
husbands of course are gonna know that
it was [ __ ] because they knew the
wife they knew the wife wasn't a witch
which is maybe while
in general which fighters [ __ ] went
after [ __ ] went after single old women
that way because there was no husband to
protect him they'd have to worry about a
husband hell bent from vengeance yeah
because like i said that's yeah you know
that shit's going to happen you go
around burning people if you're still
lives up
that's not gonna fly for long no
but yeah there are so when this movie
first came out like because i feel like
back in the old days back in 1968
um you had to submit your script like to
the sensors and stuff like that
beforehand
and
actually there was some stuff that was
in the script originally like the end
was supposed to be different i think
like vincent price was supposed to be
like more tortured before he died and
[ __ ] like that but a lot of the stuff
they didn't film it just because they
didn't have the budget you know what i
mean like they would have needed all
these other extras and stuff but there
was a lot of sequences that were taken
out there was supposed to be like a
battle sequence where a soldier got
beheaded um that was taken out like
there was a bunch of stuff that was
taken out for like censorship reasons
and even so
when the movie came out
um it wasn't censored here in the us
like i said under the conqueror room
title over there i think a couple
minutes were taken out but they've since
been restored but even then back in 1968
a lot of the critics just thought it was
just like way over the top like super
super like sadistic which it is but i
mean and particularly for the time yeah
they had to somehow compensate for the
lack of those [ __ ]
hammer boobs hammer boobs
they couldn't dig up all those boobs so
they had to get they had to wrap up the
the the the the horror a little bit i
guess yeah
because if you guys have never seen a
hammer horror film see like carmilla or
something the lesbian vampire ones there
were so many lesbian vampire movies that
was that's like a whole sub genre i i
want to say hammer's
hammer's whole [ __ ] sales pitch was
beautiful
european women of that era with just
fantastic fantastic fantastic cleavage
beautiful yeah
yeah that was the selling point and
great sets and great
costumes
and uh they're good movies hammer hammer
was not slouching it's gothic horror but
with kind of a sexual twist to it i
liked them yeah this is not like that
this is more kind of like a
down and dirty
yeah this would this would have been
torture porn for the era oh big time for
that era and the thing about it too was
that you know even though people were
kind of appalled by it in the uk
um it did okay in the uh and then it was
on like kind of the grindhouse and
drive-in circuit in the u.s because like
i said it's mostly like a foreign film
it did okay in the us as well actually
it did a really well in germany uh
probably because of that extra nudity
and you know of the sadism and stuff
yeah in a way this movie kind of kicked
off a little mini boom in
sadistic like torture which because they
made like mark of the devil like a year
after this which is also pretty good
which we should get around to we were
watching this [ __ ] now says
and i said i don't like the the title of
this which finder general says the
italian and that says what
i said the italian title would be
not my wife you witchfinder [ __ ] what
or something like that that's what that
are you witch finder [ __ ]
i was trying to come up with a real
italian giallo type [ __ ] name
something that's semi you know how you
know everything was like on the nose
with it with the italians or that yeah
it was just you know a crystal pen on a
emerald feather
i loved yellow titles so much but i mean
they called it that witch banner general
because that's what the dude's name
that's what the dude's title was that's
that was his self-appointed title was uh
it didn't hit
it's it's a tale of it's a tale of
vigilante justice though really when you
think about it pretty much and like i
said i did actually like
i was even taking it like i said this is
not by today's standards this is like
not gory at all it's not even really
that violent compared to like but for
1968
uh honestly the last scene where uh you
know richard marshall the the soldier
like ends up killing yeah
vincent price like with the axe and
everything i was just like i was just
like holy crap like look at him go you
know what i mean it's a good flick man
it is it's very watchable it's right
it's very even to this day it's an old
old movie but it's very watchable yeah
and just because the subject matter
it's good drama good yeah and like i
said this almost in in particularly in
europe this did kind of kick off a
little mini boom of like you know witch
torture type movies like i said
particularly in germany um you know if
you haven't seen mark of the devil that
that was made pretty much as a response
to this and actually mark of the devil
is pretty good too it's similar kind of
uh i think the reason why they did it
the way it was is because
the whole witch finder situation would
be very frustrating
if you're some dude
you're watching this dude come into your
town and just start accusing innocent
people this [ __ ] there's no way out so
you would feel very impotent like you
wouldn't be able to do anything
well because you couldn't do anything
they turn on you yeah so this is kind of
like the fantasy version of it well i'd
go kill that [ __ ] yeah and
that's what happens in this but in a way
that's what should have happened because
think about it yeah i wish that would
have happened that's what it should have
real life dude okay instead of him just
dying of tuberculosis or whatever you
pull up in salem and then you just and
there's all these crazy chicks [ __ ]
you know teenage chicks accusing people
of being witches and people's wives and
[ __ ] and they're just stringing them up
and hanging them and pressing them and
[ __ ] pressing them to death of stones
and even the judge
at the time was uh didn't know how to
handle it he let it happen
natural evidence yeah if i was there if
i was there with modern sensibilities
and you knew you know by some by the
stories that survived that
people knew it was [ __ ] a lot of
people knew it was [ __ ] but they
were powerless to stop it because they'd
get accused but then that's just using
terror against you well yes you got
exactly what it is you can only respond
by you can only respond to terror with
more terror that's it so i just wait
until night time out of casper dim girls
they never would have woke up
you had a casper to judge
and and then on his [ __ ] nail
something to his head do not kill
witches yeah knock it off yeah and then
and if they do it again you just casper
that next judge
because they weren't really into casper
and back then they didn't really
understand it
that's killing somebody in their sleep
you got to have the [ __ ] dexterity of
a commando you got to get in that window
you got to do that [ __ ] the way old
what's-his-name was doing it
the original night stalker d'angelo
casper the [ __ ] out of that [ __ ]
you casper a couple people back to back
it has a chilling effect that witch
hunting would go away go away real quick
yeah i mean i kind of feel like
you know it it's a no-win situation but
that's probably better than like i said
you know the whole [ __ ] town
matthew hopkins that just that one guy
that one witchfinder responsible for at
least 200 deaths at least he was a
threat to just humanity at large
yeah somebody like that just needs to be
taken out and if the system can't do it
then then that's what this story is
about the system couldn't do it it talks
about the system
the the legal framework
of his time they were not able to stop
this dude from doing it so he just had
to go outside the law and stop it yeah
which like you said it's it's better
than what actually happened it's like
self-sacrifice it's a kamikaze thing
yeah you you might go but you're going
to save hundreds of people
if you do it yeah so that's what it is
yeah but uh so yeah like i said this was
made by uh
who a couple years later would actually
make blood on satan's claw which is
actually another good it's folk horror
uh it's kind of also kind of witchcrafty
so i feel like they had a little bit of
you know a little little sub genre going
there that's distinct from amicus who
most mostly anthologies and hammer who
mostly made gothic horror but yeah oh i
wanted to say too that
oh a couple things i wanted to mention
the director of this uh michael reeves
sadly this was the last film that he
made
uh he died nine months after the
shooting he was only 25 years old
he died of an accidental barbiturate
barbiturate overdose
and alcohol
he was actually going to the next film
he was going to work on he was going to
work with vincent price again actually
he was going to work on a poe adaptation
the oblong box um he was that was the
next project that he was set to direct
but then like he went off it and then
like he died not too long after that so
he had only made two films prior to this
one was called the she beast and one was
called the sorcerers with boris karloff
and a lot of people have kind of said
that it's kind of a shame because this
film is so
iconic like in british film history it's
like you know had he lived you know
because he was so young uh had he lived
what would he have done you know
subsequently and i mean one of the
reasons that he didn't want vincent
price and was like kind of a [ __ ] about
you know telling him was that he wanted
this to be like a serious movie and he
thought that vincent price would like
ham it up yeah yeah uh so that was one
of that was the big reason so he really
wanted to make this like a serious he
thought the same thing i was yeah yeah
that's why he wanted he wrote it for
donald pleasance essentially that's who
that's who he did in it though he did
and yeah and like the director say
afterwards um i'm not really sure
because like i said he died not too long
after this um he did but i'm pretty sure
that he did like like how it turned and
vincent price actually ended up really
liking how it turned out even though
like i said the experience of making it
uh vincent price was actually thrown off
a horse a couple of times you know so
there was like a lot of
uh bad [ __ ] that happened and they
really butted heads and vincent price
said man we hated each other and that
was the first time that it ever happened
to me but when he saw the movie
afterward he thought that it came out
really well so he's like i kind of
understood like where i was going with
it so it all turned out okay in the end
and like i said i i really do think this
one of his best performances it's very
restrained for vincent price um but like
you said he does come across as very
sinister and scary and i think that it's
so it's good that he kind of like held
back as you would and i love him even to
praise i'm not saying that but i think
for this
for this particular story like with the
sadism and he knocked that apart and
stuff like that inherent in it i think
for him to have gone hammy would have
been the wrong tone
so i think that he really kind of like
he seemed to understand like he comes
off as a [ __ ] dick
he does yeah yeah he does
that's the way he has to be
yeah because like i said you don't want
this to be a fun character the dude was
a monster yeah you know what i mean and
and not like a fun monster like some of
vincent price's other [ __ ] uh this is a
serial killer yeah this was like a real
dude and he was
a [ __ ] you know what i mean so it's
you really
don't want to play him like he's like
this hammy like villain like vaudeville
type of [ __ ] no
um i also want to say too that back in
2016
uh the danish film director and i'm sure
i'm pronouncing this wrong but nicholas
winding refn the guy that did bronson
yeah and he may also made drive made the
neon demon which i'm going to do a
review on in a couple of weeks he
actually bought the remake rights to
this but i don't know uh if that's ever
going to get made but that might be
interesting to see they don't make like
a lot of
witch panic
movies
you know i don't know i think because
everything kind of goes in cycles i
don't really remember seeing i guess
they made the witch like back in 2016.
maybe that's why he bought the rights
because he's like oh we're going to do
another
you know witchcraft this type of cycle
now i'm going to get seeing pumpkinhead
a couple weeks back man kind of
kind of reminded me that you could do
some really cool wit [ __ ]
yeah and i still feel like witches are a
little bit under-represented yeah which
yeah
it's not gonna be that easy yet harley
because i love old hag witches yeah and
i just feel like yes there's some movies
and and like i said they did the witch a
few years back with you know that was
actually set around that time period
yeah too but in the u.s
and i just kind of wish that i don't
know i just feel like as much as as many
of them as they make i just feel like
they should do more of it yeah well like
you said when we saw grendel and hansel
you were just like we we would they need
a whole movie about just the witches
yeah she didn't give a [ __ ] about the
other [ __ ] just that witch was doing
some [ __ ] bad ass yeah that was
what's her name that was alice creed
that was in yeah joe's story and then
nasty look at that she got hot one time
she got nasty and she's eating children
and stuff they just it needs to be done
the right way it has to be the right
movie the right script
it'd be better if it was not just one
witch but several of them and they're
all bad and they're fighting each other
that would be cool battle between
witches and you have it almost kind of
like
see they're satanic as [ __ ] it's almost
kind of like a star wars movie that
would be nothing but sith lords fighting
each other yeah that was yeah
over like a sith holocron so in other
words which is going after some kind of
a
evil relic
and um you know they're not real
physical all the time but you know
just
you just have to write a really good
story about it
and like i said i do kind of feel like
there was you know there was a time back
in the late 60s early 70s where there
were a lot of movies set during the
witch panics in the us and in europe and
i kind of feel like there's not a lot of
those anymore so i don't know maybe a
remake of this will materialize
where the which story or which movie
there wouldn't be any good guys in it
none
it would be just between these witches
and they'd just all be evil all witch
all the time all witch all the time
all bad
stinky ass [ __ ] hoes
[ __ ] up hair
and they might get hot for it but it's
just a it's just an illusion
to
and then they're fighting each other and
they're trying to do something that's
bad their goal that they're trying to
achieve is bad there wouldn't be any
good people in it i'm gonna take you
down into the damn spiritual underworld
of witch stuff
out in some [ __ ] evil swamp somewhere
that's what it should be i would watch
that yeah when do you think that'd be
cool yeah that could be a whole series a
whole series yeah of evil witches yeah
people would watch that yeah i mean
there's lots of series nowadays where
like everyone's bad guys everybody's a
bad guy and then
bad guys are bad guys are interesting
the only time you see mortals or
non-witches their children are getting
eaten
or something like that you know
somebody's going to be sacrificed
they're just like the cannon fodder yeah
yeah
yeah i would totally watch that but yeah
so uh so shutter
just added witchfinder general not too
long ago like i said in the u.s
it's still known as edgar allan poe's
conqueror or worm even though it doesn't
have anything to do with edgar allan poe
um you know except like i said the us
version of spencer price reading the
bits of that poem like over the
beginning and the end just so they could
slap that on there but uh yeah i i
honestly prefer witchfinder general as a
title because it actually has something
to do with the movie uh but yeah so if
you if you like vincent price and you
haven't seen this one you want to see
him like play an actual like sinister
bad guy instead of like a theatrical bad
guy then um definitely watch this it's
kind of like we said it was kind of like
torture porn for 1968 it's very tame by
today's standards but for back then uh
it was pretty hardcore like showing
people like getting pricked in the back
and yeah still good story though and
[ __ ] like that yeah and it's just pretty
straightforward it's about 30
historically accurate um you know as far
as some of the people being real and
[ __ ] like that um but it's basically
like a revenge story and like you said
something that should have happened to
that [ __ ] but didn't um and a
lot like i said a little bit like a
western too almost like a worcester
western but british folk horror
witchcraft type of
thing you know what i mean uh but yeah
so it's on shutter i'm sure it's
probably other places too i've heard
there's a nice blu-ray release that i
don't i don't know if it was arrow or
scream factory or somebody put it out
but yeah that was supposedly has like a
lot of good extras on it as well so uh
go and check it out it's uh pretty
[ __ ] cool and that'll do it for this
movie retrospective we will see you guys
on the next one bye